parts of New York City are gridlocked
this week because of the annual meeting
of the UN General Assembly an elite
group of NYPD motorcycle officers is
guiding serval world leaders to and from
the united nation only on CBS this
morning we have an inside look at the
team Kris Van Cleave is outside from
tower in Manhattan a present Trump is
staying Chris good morning good morning
these officers are waiting to take
president Trump when he leaves home over
to the UN or wherever he needs to go
today
there are more than 120 world leaders in
town for the UN that means more than 170
motorcades have to be done it's a lot of
work and the occult goal here is to get
the dignitaries where they need to go as
quickly and as safely as possible as
they ride past it looks so easy
nearly two dozen motorcycles clearing
the way for the president but it's the
culmination of a year's worth of
planning in practice President Trump is
just one of 11 world leaders currently
attending the UN General Assembly that
get a continuous high risk
NYPD escort as long as they're in New
York is this kind of like the motorcade
superbowl through here exactly
Thomas Chan is the chief of
transportation for the NYPD and also a
former motorcycle officer we call them
the a-team they are the best riders in
highway district they're selected
because they're still long before they
hop on a Harley and lead a motorcade
they have to make it through a grueling
20 day training course
only about half pass we got special
access to their training facility and
watched officers practice motorcades a
few ride ahead looking for potential
threats and if needed blocked roads
until the motorcade passes then race to
get back to the front others stand a
wedge formation in front of the
President or dignitary we have to be
ready for everything
sergeant Joseph Murphy is riding in the
president's motorcade this week during
his 35-year career he's worked on at
least 75 presidential escorts well I can
tell the new students when they come
into the motorcycle school when they
came on this job
they get a ticket to every major event
in the city and when they're in the
Highway Patrol they get a front-row seat
now this job is not without its risks
there have been several officers injured
or even killed in motorcade accidents in
recent years this unit also escorts the
vice president even the Pope and any
visiting heads of state that come
outside of the UN General Assembly when
they're not doing that these guys make
up the Highway Patrol Gayle all right
Thank You Kris Van Cleave always good to
have a front row seat to anything I
think and when the motorcade was leaving
the building today guys you have to
admit it's a very impressive sight when
they rolled down the street whoo nice to
have that moving around New York would
know wouldn't it though Charlie were
there two there lickety-split liked it
thank you Chris